lakovic 19 à emporter la maire de lille
grenier le 30 avril 2020 au début de la
pandémie les derniers moments d'anita
roy ont été difficiles cette veuve de 90
ans vivait aussi h et celle des lots
rien lepage dans l'est de montréal après
et pc avec une marchette
mais elle avait besoin d'elle pour elle
bouleverse la vie des choses comme ça et
aucun quant à rentrer là le gros si
ottawa avait maigri c'est à travers une
fenêtre que sa soeur chantal a vu sa
mère pour la dernière fois
anita roi s'en est allé quatre jours
plus tard lise a été la seule personne
autorisée à se rendre à son chevet
lacava
mais moi j'ai enlevé mes liens jeu
l'enlever mon masque je l'embrassé gîte
julie flatté je lui ai parlé ce que
massa repris mes deux frères ont pas
fait on peut faire puisque la ct
c'est du pain complet ici pour résoudre
parce que les autres lions pas eu la
chance de l'avoir
les funérailles de madame roy devait
avoir lieu l'automne dernier mais avec
l'arrivée de la deuxième vague
la famille a préféré reporter la
cérémonie celle ci aura finalement lieu
le 21 ou 2021 soit 15 mois après le
décès qui met même année j'y suis ça
fait un an et demi on annule titre parce
que les arrangements avait été faite le
9 septembre 2020 taquin maniche damas a
fini par causer dont on annule structure
puis d'autres citons massa reste j'en ai
pas question mme amara mérite un service
général j'ai aucun problème avec ce
répit tuellement l'état d'accord avec la
pandémie a été un obstacle pour le deuil
de bien des familles qui n'ont pas pu se
rassembler pour célébrer la vie de leur
proche c'est l impossibilité de pouvoir
se réunir on romy dans un premier temps
au delà de 5 10 personnes ont besoin
dans les premiers temps et après on l'a
vu pendant de nombreux mois jusqu'à
maximum 25 personnes dans les cas de co
vide
le ministère de la santé avait également
demandé à l'industrie funéraire de
disposer des dépouilles
en moins de 48 heures elle ne pouvait
pas être exposée mais la famille avait
le choix soit de l'incinérer ou de
l'inhumer c'est-à-dire de l'enterrer il
est toujours éprouvant de perdre un être
cher mais la pandémie semble-t-il a
rendu ce passage obligé encore plus
difficile tant sur le plan individuel
que collectif
on va avoir des dettes qui sont reportés
c'est ce qu'on vit actuellement de plus
en plus mais ces deuils là pour avoir
les meilleures conditions possibles
doivent être accompagnées de gestes ces
gestes là sont ces rituels et c'est la
chose la plus importante que nous vivons
actuellement et par la possibilité de
nouveau de se réunir en plus grands
groupes
on va offrir cette possibilité les
funérailles d'anita roi le mois prochain
permettront de lui rendre l'hommage
posthume qu'elle n'a pas eu l aideront
aussi ses proches a enfin vivre leur
deuil convenablement
là on va pouvoir finir tout ensemble
avec ses petits-enfants six avec cinq
ans puis les belles-soeurs un beau-frère
parce qu'on
je pense que méritée sur je pense que ça
va vraiment mettre le point final à tous
les disques sony a pu dire au revoir à
sa mère
les autres membres de la famille
pourront maintenant lui dire adieu à
leur manière ici jérôme l'abbé radio
canada mon frère